[Applause]
you didn't even earlier start in in show
business uh i believe it was a christmas
show how was it were you four in your
christmas show i was four when i got my
my big break yeah yeah yeah but now you
did have problems
yeah well i had one line um uh and it
was a uh
it was a nativity play which is familiar
to most of us
and uh i just wanna obviously one of the
three wise men obviously and uh you had
a beard yeah exactly
no
i didn't
and i had to i know i'm from northern
ireland which is a
peculiar little place where they we
speak quite funny
and we a lot of words sound the same
like a lot of words you could you're not
sure what you said anyway i was the guy
who brought the the the murr
which when i say it is just like
reflective glass
you know what i mean like that's what so
i was like and then what have you
brought in the gold
and you brought the frankenstein i was
like oh my god and what have you brought
and i was like the mirror
and they asked me to repeat it
i'm sorry
because i guess it's meant to sound
slightly different to that and they said
again
i brought the mirror
like a tiny different note on it i liked
it that joseph asked you again what
hey i'm sorry how old were you four four
i know okay you know that's tough yeah
nobody made an adjustment to the
dialogue
no you could tell like you changed it i
see the star in me then yeah
that's what you're trying to say yeah
myrrh
[Music]
you